después de más de cinco décadas de
servicio anthony fauci anunció que
dejara lo que ha llamado el honor de
toda una vida como el principal experto
en enfermedades infecciosas del país
false y dejará sus cargos como asesor un
médico jefe de la casa blanca y como
director del instituto nacional de
alergias y enfermedades infecciosas de
eeuu entidad que dirige desde 1964
y dejaré estos puestos en diciembre de
este año para seguir el próximo capítulo
de mi carrera en un comunicado del
presidente joe biden le agradeció por su
labor
al dejar su puesto en el gobierno de
eeuu sé que el pueblo estadounidense y
el mundo entero seguirán beneficiándose
de la experiencia del doctor fauci en lo
que sea que haga a continuación eeuu es
más fuerte más resistente y más
saludable gracias a él su papel durante
la pandemia fue determinante y lo
convirtió en una cara conocida en todo
el país desde el inicio de la crisis
lideró de esfuerzos científicos para
desarrollar y probar vacunas de kobe 19
y realizaba periódicamente sesiones
informativas sobre la evolución
epidémica en el país esta labor fue
ampliamente respaldada por expertos de
salud pública sin embargo no fue una
tarea fácil ni valorada por todos
durante el gobierno de donald trump uno
de sus principales contradictores fue
precisamente el presidente el
republicano arremetió en diversas
ocasiones contra él cuestionando los
llamados de fauci a no reabrir la
economía antes de tiempo para evitar
rebrotes lo que causó la ira del
mandatario además de múltiples ataques
partidistas e incluso amenazas de muerte
antes de su rol central durante la
pandemia de coronavirus en fauci también
había liderado otras crisis sanitarias
como la del sida durante los años 80 y
trabajó también por combatir diversas
enfermedades infecciosas